because your life as you know it is
ancient history
[Music]
have you ever noticed that most of the
schools we see in movies and TV read
about in novels or even hear about in
songs are terrible rotten places what is
this place prison for children where
you're likely to get Pig's blood dumped
on you at prom get beaten up on the
playground or humiliated by classmates
and teachers alike we take for granted
that K-12 education is like living in
Orwell's 1984 or serving a prison
sentence
[Music]
but there are exceptions in fiction and
in real life
when you get to choose where you go to
school you're guaranteed a better
experience because you've picked a place
where you actually want to be and that
will treat you well because they know
you can leave if you want to currently
only about a quarter of K-12 students
attend something other than their local
public schools places like Charters
magnets or private institutions or home
school
if more kids had more choice schools
would do a better job of responding to
their specific needs and helping them
become the best version of themselves
there's no one-size-fits-all in
education any more than there is in
clothing or shoes here are three
fictional schools which are great not
because they're right for everyone but
because they meet the unique needs of
their particular students
hello Scott welcome to the school for
the gifted
[Music]
you're enrolled
entry to Professor X's Academy of super
powered mutants is By Invitation Only
but it comes with a free ride and a
promise to learn how to control and
master each student's special powers
Professor X and his faculty hold
everyone to exacting high standards but
also make sure nobody slips through the
cracks the sort of attention that is all
too lacking in schools that take
students and the tuition dollars they
represent for granted
[Music]
hang on back there here we go
welcome to Sky High 2005 Sky High
showcased another superhero High School
one filled with comic takes on
Traditional School drama but it also
featured Gym classes that actually seem
like your opponents and save the
citizens
uh I remember when we used to use real
citizens yes the students are quickly
assigned to either a hero track if they
display superpowers or a sidekick track
if they don't
hero and a handsome one at that
but unlike Too Many real life schools
the kids are able to change courses if
they demonstrate new abilities
super strong
Dear Mr Potter we are pleased to inform
you that you have been accepted at a
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry
you're a wizard Harry
and of course there's Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry the school at
the center of the Harry Potter series
modeled on hide-bound British boarding
schools and century-old universities
like Oxford and Cambridge Hogwarts is
filled with bullies arbitrary rules
customs and demanding teachers
but in the end what makes this
institution unique is the philosophy of
its Headmaster Albus Dumbledore who
forces his greatest pupil to master not
only the magical Arts but a basic
philosophical Maxim too
it is not our abilities that show what
we truly are
it is our choices
these places are wonderful because they
don't take their students for granted
they take them seriously and push them
toward excellence and accomplishment
while treating them as Unique
Individuals schools don't need to be
dreary downbeat hell holes whether we're
talking movies or real life if more of
us get to choose where we go we'll be
smarter happier and maybe even better
adjusted and our movies will eventually
reflect that no McFly ever amounted to
anything in the history of Hill Valley
yeah well history is going to change
[Music]